so uh margaret is going to tell us about
uh we are very pleased to have uh
santa cruz he is going to tell us about
uh the blessing and curse of uh
right the multiplicative update i've
worked on this for a very long time and
this topic makes me tick in various ways
as a human citizen on on the earth i
think about globalization i also have a
farming background
i garden a lot and do a lot of different
things and this ties it all together and
hopefully it will be obvious
so what is a multiplicative update
it's an algorithm that maintains weight
vectors
and the weights are multiplied by
non-negative
and this occurs
you're forced into this regime when you
have concentrations
and concentrations cannot go negative
this is my my my sense of it so nature
because it has concentrations of genes
it has number of species that survive of
a particular kind you're already
immediately forced into this regime in
machine learning we have other methods
we have additive updates where you do
gradient descent you ski
but then you have to have negative
weights
and that's fundamentally different
so this is the multiplication it's
motivated by relative entropy as a
regular regularizer
okay here's the simple typical machine
learning setting i'm doing very simple
machine learning
multiplicative updates
they are kind of asexual totally boring
but i want to get a point across and
then i add always a little bit of a
trick to improve them and i show that
that trick is necessary in what it does
so typically we have a set of experts
that do something on the trial by trial
basis
and s.i
is the share of a particular expert i
used some biology notation because i
teach classes with biologists and and
economies on evolutionary computation
and stuff like that so so si is sort of
the weight of the ice expert or the
share of the ice expert and then the
multiplicative update is something like
new weight is old weight times a factor
non-negative factor that's very
important
it's e to the minus eight or loss
loss could be a fitness rate and this is
the fitness
in biology this is usually called big wi
and then you normalize
and i claim that base is a special case
of this base is the fundamental thing
for updating conditional probabilities
bayes rule if you put a log likelihood
up here then this becomes
um posterior is prior times data
likelihood over normalization i will
bring that obvious in a moment and
uh
i'm going to
in the i'm going to show how to
implement base
at a very large scale so the weights in
nature are concentrations
shares of genes in a population
and they update it multiplicatively
that's
that's
the connection to these machine learning
algorithms we didn't know this
connection at all when we started doing
multiplicative updates
uh first person was in my community was
nick littlestone and then we did lots of
work on this i've been working on this
ever since but the connections to
biology only in the last 10 15 years
okay
good so the blessing of the
multiplicative update as i will bring
out is its speed
it does
multiply by factors so you get sort of
this exponential growth
okay and that's a problem
it's good and it's bad okay it's bad
because you have a loss of diversity if
you run this album for a long time many
iterations one guy wins
and you have die out
and
that is why
multiplicative updates are good and
that's why they're bad and if you don't
have a mechanism for
fighting the curse you will be in
trouble and i will bring that out can i
show you how we do it in machine
learning and then i made more and more
connections to biology and it's kind of
mind-bogglingly interesting i think
okay so we'll give four machine learning
methods for which we can prove things i
don't know anything about proofs here
but we can prove things
they all sort of information
theoretically optimal
uh um
and then i discuss related ones in
nature okay next i'm going to implement
the base in the tube
for that
i do it a totally different
trivial multiplicative update and that
is uh in vitro selection that in the
nights 1960 or started it
so you have a soup of random rna strands
in this tube right here's my cup i have
props
okay so
and you tip in a sheet of rna a sheet of
a protein and what you want to do is you
want to select for a strand
that
that attaches to the protein this is
true this is important for medicine
because you have to get the agent to the
place where you want it okay
so
you uh tip
pull out wash off the washer of the rna
that's stuck
and then multiply washed off rna rna
back to the original amount
because you have to amplify because when
you when you only a small amount
attaches so now you have to amplify what
attached this is the good stuff to the
unit amount so you have still the same
amount of rna you had before
okay
so this cannot be done with a computer
actually this particular simulation
you cannot simulate with a computer
because you have avogadro many uh uh
strands if they're short enough you have
10 to the 20 strands but i'm going to
show you how to do a multiplicative
update with 10 to the 20 strands and
later on i'm going to do an exponential
blow up that learns these junctions over
these strands using winnow that then
would be if you learn a 10 literal
disjunction would be you learn concepts
10 to the 20 and then power 10 again
it's mind boggling the speed what you
can do with this very simple thing
okay so the fundamental thing is you
start
with a unit amount of random rna strands
you can generate those there's
techniques for doing that and then you
have a loop and do a functional
separation into the good rna and the bad
rna the good one is the one that
attaches to the protein to the sheet the
bad one that doesn't detach and then you
amplify
amplify
the good rna to the unit amount are you
with me so it's very boring
multiplicative update
very simple no sex okay
okay good now there is a trick for
um
duplicating rna so you have all the
strands in your soup you can duplicate
okay
this was invented by carrie moulies i
usually show a slide but a slight show
on this but over times now more and more
people know about this so i i stopped
doing it
so it's invented by karen mullins he's
he was in lake tahoe in a in a hot
spring and on an lsd trip and he
supposedly invented his thing that's the
only result that i know of
that was of that sort um
so uh so what you do is and he actually
was in the hot springs and he knew
there's life forms here and it gave him
the idea right
and so this this life form had to
duplicate so maybe how do they do it and
then he asked that question he extracted
the life form
and
extracted a certain
tag polymerase that does it okay so what
you do is hot springs yellowstone yes
uh in yellowstone or in playground
you know science there's rumors i don't
know what's the truth
okay i don't know which one he was
bathing in but the
organ he got it from there okay good he
was bathing supposedly okay it doesn't
matter so
so you have your double stranded
everything is double stranded when you
heat it up it becomes single stranded
okay and then you have primers that the
ends of these all of these guys are
similar
are the same and then you have short
spri primers they become doubled so you
have now a single strand and at the end
you have already doubled and now you
have a polymerase that walks around and
doubles the the single strand it doubles
everything up
and now essentially
you are back to a double-stranded dna
and ideally each dna strand
all the dna strands are multiplied by a
factor of two
okay
that's ideally
but there's a hitch to that you will see
okay
so the main problem with this kind of
research is it was very exciting back
then they wanted to do evolution it's
kind of like the genetic algorithm from
computer scientists
in computer science there's a lot of
excitement but it didn't quite go very
far because it's very difficult to get
smart functional separations
that you can do at a high level that's
sort of the problem and i've worked a
lot on
computational drug design that uses
different tricks but that's a separate
talk but now what i want to do is i want
to formalize that multiplicative update
and i claim that using that tube you can
run base
okay good
so we name our our rna strands the 10 to
the 20. we just call them 1 to 10 to the
20.
the naming is not important it's just
for the purpose of the description okay
now the s i
oh the s i is the share of the eighth
strand the fraction
okay and of course the share vector
sums to one
right it sums to one that's the share
vector the total is one so this is a
probability vector
so by one of my tubes the tubes with my
the tube with my rna stand is a
probability vector
okay
good
so now
there's also a fitness factor this is
the amount
of
um
rnai that attaches so w5
might have 50 of attaching
this is a number between zero and one
that's this kind of number
so i call it the fraction of one unit of
rnai that is good that attaches
okay
so this is the fitness of rna strand i
for attaching to the protein protein i'm
trying to put some biology terms in
there again
my
cup
my tube is a vector the s vector this is
another vector an attachment vector
the protein yeah
so you have two vectors
and now it goes on
we don't know the vectors we just named
them
so we never go down and sequence the dna
and do something like that or know what
the protein does we just abstractly
describe the vectors it's kind of like
kernelization and machine learning
we only rely on the dot products and of
course every good science has an
assumption
otherwise it's not good science so the
assumption here is that wi is
the the the um
attachment vector is independent of the
shares
uh it's a natural assumption if the
concentrations are very small
okay good so the sugars are the fraction
the fraction yes so now i tell you what
attaches what attaches is
well
i have this much of rna one this is the
amount that attaches okay this one of
two so it's a dot product wow now we
have machine learning we've got products
okay the complement is what doesn't
attach it's of course the other part the
total is of course one
okay
now what's the amplification well the
good share
of rnai is this much
it's multiplied by a factor
and then afterwards it sums to one if
you do a little calculation you know
that the factor is this much and the
final update that
in other words
s i is s i times its fitness over
normalization now if that is not a
multiplicative update okay
fine
so
you call s i the prior
w i
called the probability of good given i
and the dot product good
it's probability of good so i'm just
using uh
sort of high level probability language
and then this update bam becomes
posterior
which is the concentration of i given
you a good
it's this it's the prior times data
likelihood over normalization so that's
space rule so you do base rule with 10
to the 20 variables
okay
and you do it in your kitchen
you can do it anywhere
by just pouring right that's how you do
base through 10 to the 20 variables and
you in some sense you never you don't
even sequence you know nothing it's
blind computation
okay
so i'm going to show now to start with
this is my core as an extremely boring
multiplicative update
i will show you things cannot be done
with this and what you have to do to
make it powerful
there's no mutations yet you've got a
fixture no mutation boring boring but
i'm going to introduce notations in a
moment okay so now first i want to show
you how these updates behave
so these are particular plots
here the concentrations are three
species green blue red these are the
concentrations point six point four and
a tiny amount of red
okay now this is time so you multiply
what happens is
red fitness factor is 0.8
now rate is 0.9 green is 0.8 sorry for
all the males in the audience this is
red this is green and this is red and uh
blue is 0.75
okay so you multiply by this factor and
we normalize multiplied by the fact and
each trial multiplied by the factor and
we normalize do you understand it's a
very simple update
this is the initial concentration and
this is the initial fitness everybody
understand this plot
now what happens is
initially you have this guy which has a
lower factor blue and a lower factor
than
green you know has a
right so of course this guy wins out but
then this good guy that comes out of the
dark that had very low concentration
feeds them beats this one and eventually
this guy wins so one guy wins okay
that's the main important thing that i
want to make here's another one
two guys are very close to each other
very little difference in the
multiplicative factor
makes round get better than green
but eventually this guy which has a
higher factor of 0.9 beats them both
you can do all kinds of tricks with it
you can go to negative time i cut out
the slides too many things okay good
so
the best the problem is the best are too
good
multiplicative updates shares multiplied
by fitness factor over normalization
but the blessing is you get fast you can
do it with 10 to 20 variables because
you can prove that the number of updates
you need to bring it up is somehow
related to the log of the number of
things and log of 10 to the 20 is not
much
but the best the curse is the best wipe
out others and you have a loss of
variety
loss of diversity i don't know what the
right term is last time i talked to my
housemate who is a soil scientist he
studied ecology which word should i use
diversity or variety we got a huge
argument and he said he mentioned
evenness and all kinds of other things
simple simple and we actually agreed on
diversity that's the word
okay
so the simple view of evolution is you
have inheritance you have mutation and
you select for the fittest
with the multiplicative update
okay now the new view is and this is
what i'm going to talk about here is
that the multiplicative updates are
extremely brittle when you put things
into the exponents things go
blah it goes bad very quickly very
dangerous so a mechanism is needed to
ameliorate at the curse of the
multiplicative update it's going to be
short term versus long term the short
term is going to be multiplicative and
the long term is over something else
and machine learning in nature uses
various methods i will show you the ones
we found and you can uh and r then and
see oh does nature do this as well
you'll see
okay good
so let me show another tube experiment
you take
a tube and you put in a hundred
different bacteria in there on a
nutrient solution
and you just let it sit how many survive
you wait this competition
and typically and people i designed this
experiment and then i found it in papers
and
they three survive one in the muck on
the bottom typically one on the side and
one on the surface so they found three
niches
one on the mac
one on the side there was still light
but you but but but it's still oxygen
disturbed and on the top you have oxygen
it's order of three of course right
so a small number survives now here
comes the
fundamental deep question
um
you do the same experiment but you
agitate the tube you put it on a
magnetic exterior i do that a lot when i
grow um
spirulina and stuff like that so you
have a magnetic steria and you uh put it
on and then you do the same experiment
and now how many survive
one why because you have only one niche
no you often get many but that's no well
yes
first order approximation okay i it gets
very subtle
because it turns out that the genome is
part of the environment and it's very
messy so you don't get total mixing
in some sense
okay good
so i believe that this is actually one
of the main problems of the human
endeavor it's not necessarily global
warming
what happens is we a global warming is
one of them we are connecting the world
with roads
roads could be tools that we invented it
could be an iphone it could be all kinds
of things i call them roads in quote
and they cause mixing and therefore we
have a loss of variety so this is uh the
as a world citizen i'm very much
concerned with this i believe
by you the human endeavor in her
enhances right now
the multiplication the curse of the
multiplicative update and we have global
die out
why is this bad you figure it out
okay i could talk about that okay let's
go on
so now i'm going to show you
a first key problem that cannot be
solved by the multiplicative update
alone
okay
and they have to have a fix and then i
show you how nature fixes it and it's an
amazing little fix
okay so
here's my tube i drew it as a square i
apologize
and you have some concentration of three
strands in there you don't know what
they are they're not separated like this
it's a it's a soup
and the task is how do you make more of
the soup with a multiplicative update
i claim you cannot in particular you
cannot do it with pcr
if you apply pcr
these rna strands are folded ever so
slightly they hug the tag polymerases c
might have a survival factor of 1.91
and this one would be 1.8 and this one
1.97
so
if you apply the multiplicative update
many times pcr in many states you can do
this automated now robots can do it very
very fast
what happens is one guy will win
so this is a task that the
multiplicative update cannot do
you cannot compensation causes die out
diversity is lost
so how do you uh does anybody know how
to fix this problem
with rna technology say any rna people
here dna people i'm only a layman first
transcriptics
yeah something like that so what you do
is
you add stickers to the end of the rna
strands and make along and they stick
together you can do that and you make a
long strand
and now
you have this long strand and then you
can put a special primer at the
beginning at the end and you fish out
one of those long strands so you pick
and on the long strands roughly the
right amount of a b and c are on these
strands
there's an error of course because
because because you're random sampling
and there's a big error it's not precise
but the point is once you have the long
strand the error doesn't blow up
okay why because you have a primer at
the beginning at the end and now you
amplify
you can amplify you can set it up so
always the full
strand is copied the full strand is
copied
you can do that using primers at the
beginning at the end you make one long
strand yes you mean that you you
the
randomness you take your stoop you take
your soup you add these sticky ends they
attach to the end and then they make
long chains there's no they're not a and
c specific it's not here no no they're
not anc specific
yes they're not nsa specific they
correct yes and there's an error of
course but it doesn't blow up and then
you do pcr on this and then you chop
into constituents
constituents
and
so the long strands function as
chromosomes and free-floating genes in
the nucleus would compete you would get
lots of diversity
and here's the picture
so what happens is
if you have the a and b in parallel
apply pcr competition one guy wins
if they are linked together here
and you apply pcr
then
then actually
you compete for the best
variant of a and b and it forces a
cooperation so it's like this
there's a handshake
and it's and actually you can see it's
cooperative in some sense it looks like
that but then there's a tie knot
you're forced in this together
so i would be competing router and i
will now compete with other variants
leslie and
and uh
um
christos who also may be a pair we
compete and now we are not competing
against each other we are competing
against other pairs
and this is a fundamentally deep thing
and this is how nature solved this
problem using this kind of coupling
there's all kinds of tricks
in the cell that make sure that
everybody gets copied and it's fair
yes
so
when you have all these um you put these
sticky things in there right yes in your
tube you're going to have a lot of long
strands yes some of them will have 45
percent yes
yes
you pick a random strand
you pick a random strand you can
thin you can thin out onto petrol dishes
or whatever and figure out is there a
strand there
and then if you have a random of the
right long size you use that so you're
able to pick one
yes
yes that becomes your chromosome and
then you apply pcr to that
okay
good
so we cooperate actually i went to the
to the sex store to got a
handcuffs
but i forgot them inside
okay
so
so there's many questions already about
in retail selection
okay which is a bare bones evolutionary
process
okay
so what updates
represent
an iteration of individual selection
what updates are possible with line
computation
and the crucial thing that we always are
forced to do when we have concentration
is when we have uh this kind of thing we
have to update mods and concentrations
non-negative weights and we somehow
there's not many updates left
because you have to update
the concentrations at this point there's
no selection they're all being amplified
together
and they amplify together but the
selection is based on the fitness factor
there is selection
selection i have already i haven't
talked about mutation yet
you selected first and then
okay in this particular experiment in
the earlier one when i did base rule i
had selection in this particular
experiment what i'm saying is
if you want to do this thing
you'd get a long strand and then you
just duplicate and get more of the same
soup okay there's no selection here yes
in this particular thing i'm gonna do
other ones you'll see
well it depends on both the fitness
depends on both and now
you are going to
select for fitness
select for good combinations of a and b
and i call that a and b sort of
cooperate they have to cooperate the
genes have to co they our genes get our
bodies out there and do all of these
things make love and do all of these
things
and work and come to lectures
so that we get more offspring it's a
pretty roundabout way it's kind of
unbelievable but that's what
what is believed to be
biology okay the genes drive it now i'll
give you another example
another example where the multiplicative
that the multiplicative update by itself
cannot solve and this was solved by
window which
is a little bit of a contradiction so
um but i will bring it out in a moment
so you have the same thing with proteins
as before
but you have different proteins in one
trial you have protein one you protein
two you have a bunch of proteins and you
want to find a soup that attaches to all
of them
so in some sense you want to find a
union that does the job
and you want to define in a decoupled
way
okay
so each time you do your thing
tip p1 in there
wash off
and
amplify pick tp2 in there wash off and
so forth
can you figure out
how to attach to all of them without
in with blind computation
you will see a multiplicative update by
itself has a problem
blind you mean without knowing the w i's
without knowing the w
yes yes without knowing anything about
what's in the soup okay
okay so look here assume there's two
guys in there that do the job
a k equals two you know
there's one that attaches
well to these two
high factors and one to these
you see and it's ideally what you want
is you want to have this
tube with con where everybody has
concentration 10 to the minus 20 and
arrive at this two because that does the
job how do you do that with blind
computation
we know figured this out
okay
that's nick littlestone
you have to explain this a little bit
more yes yes yes yes yes calm down
so now
so the goal is you start with a tube
where everybody has frequency 10 to the
20 and you want to arrive at this
so here's those
specific two where you want to arrive
all possible pairs no no
you don't know what the two are you
assuming you have a tube and assume two
can do the job
can you find them
can you can you do the job can you raise
their concentrations together you see in
a decoupled fashion because they are not
coupled on one gene w1 and w2 these are
this is free floating first rna strand
free floating second rna strand
so i go against what i did with a
handshake here
but still there's a fix it's totally
fascinating
okay
so
so you do this
okay how do you do this well if you over
train with p1 and p2
if you over train with these two
examples
then
the first rna strand will blow up and
will dominate you have a multiplicative
update huge factor differences
and this guy will dominate if you over
train with this
you have a uh then then the second one
will dominate and this this is a problem
it is highly unstable okay here's how we
know fixed it
okay you want to do blind computation so
here's the abstract problem for the
machine learners
your instances are bit vectors
your weight vector is a that you're
looking for is a disjunction one over k
and k position
and you want to look for something
uh that this is sort of expresses the
disjunction and you want to use this
thresholding to figure out whether
you're in or out so this is sort of the
machine learning thing
how does the update work the update does
the following
this is the good side the good rna
if that is bigger than a certain
threshold
then what you do is you do not update
why is w a function of t
because because each time a different
protein sheet is tipped in i called it
wt i thought there were k different
projects
they skate different things that do the
job
sorry yeah okay good so
if a lot of it attaches
then you don't update wait sorry
you have wt1 and wt2 you have two
different sets of
rnas or um okay there's two things going
on there's the weight vector in which
case where you have two strands that you
want to select for and then you have
tasks and the two strands cover the task
in some sense
in the sense that
the first
has a high factor on some of them
the second one has a high factor on some
of the proteins together they cover all
of them it's a disjunction
that's the idea together
they cover all proteins look at this
picture
this picture here
there's a red factor a high factor on
all five cases they cover all of them
that's that's the point i want to get
across
so they cover all of
the sheets
but you don't know how what the cover is
and so forth and you still want to do it
and the way you do it is
you do this you should imagine that
there are many rows yes
different colors yeah basically two
colors cover everything two wireless
captions it's a set cover problem right
for the computer scientist and what so
what you do in this you want in blind
computation so you do a thresholding
spam
and if
the good side is large sorry you've gone
now from wt1 wt2 yeah back to just wt
so what is the relationship wt
at each trial i get a new i get my
current my current vector
of concentrations
i
see what attaches
and this is the protein that i tip in
right
i measure the dot product and if it's
bigger than the threshold if a lot of it
attaches then i don't do my update and i
will show you in a moment why i don't do
that i just i just don't do pcr
if
however not enough attaches if you're
below the threshold then you do a
multiplicative update
and you can show this as information
theoretically optimal
the number of updates of this type you
need is k times log n over k which is
the number of bits to encode the
disjunction we do proofs we do
everything and we know that uh nickels
did this yes
are you going to tell us no
no that's that's that's 30 years old
okay we'll get like we'll get to the new
stuff
okay
so now um
so this is the first trick in what is we
know yes
it's a version of widow with one with
with all the examples being positive i
did normalize minor for some reason
which is a very good value okay good so
ml1 is you prevent over training using
the conservative update that's the first
trait
so assume so but it knows it assumes
that you can measure this concentration
so if you call this still blind it's a
dot product okay then you're fine
the normalizer can be implemented with
blank computation the algorithm uses n
weights
one pair rna strand a concentration bar
rna strand i didn't go via the coupling
trick i didn't make up
one
one rna strand per disjunction then i
would have 10 assume i have a 10 liter
of disjunction i would have 10 to the 20
to the 10 different things that's too
much
this is too many combinations lower but
i still can use this many concept
efficiently it's mind-boggling trick
okay can you say
what is n
n is the number of strands in the soup
k is the size of this junction
is basically the things that you know i
had k equals 2
i had k equals 2 and n was 10 to the 20.
okay good now so you can do this so now
i'm going to do other tricks next trick
i can't wait and i actually learned this
from my class with berry cenero and dan
friedman
you need to know k to tune it but we are
working on this non-stop i tell me for
the last 30 years work on these
non-steps to try to to get rid of these
tuning parameters we got rid of all of
them recently using dropout it's a long
story separate time and k has to be less
than the number of tubes
a k has to be the number of literals
that you're going for which is less than
the number of tubes that you have
potentially to select on yeah sure
how do you do the thresholding
biologically biologically what you do is
you would and i talked to dna guys you
would look at your tube that you wash
the stuff that you washed up and you
send some kind of radioactive you need
grad students to do this you
you can send some kind of radioactive
light through it
and uh
you measure
outside
so the next thing you're going to cap
weights
okay i need to go
i'm not doing i have one taupe that i
trained with but i tip in different
sheets
okay okay
so now
so here's capping from the top so this
is the predator idea the super predator
idea if you have a lion species in the
serengeti it's specialized it has to
invest into what it learns
what it learns to hunt it takes a lot of
time to learn how to hunt buffalo cake
buffalo very very nasty animal has
highly highly defensive
it's it's it's a match so they have to
learn how to match
to hunt them so essentially they have to
spit they specialize on the most
frequent prey so in other words they eat
off the top of the bar
okay and i designed caching strategies
using this and so forth and eventually
we found an amazing application so
here's your simplex
you update with multiplicative weights
but then if you cap let's say capped
with a half then it turns out you have a
smaller polytope and this has
exponentially many corners
um
what you do is when you cap is you do
the multiplication updating the weights
that's outside
you take it away and distribute it
proportionally this is sort of
technically what happens
motivated with relative end everything
is always motivated with relative
entropy regularization so what happens
is
these corners of the simplex correspond
to sets of size two
here
tetrahedron four-dimensional simplex
represented as a three-dimensional
tetrahedron then this is an octahedron
each corner of the eight corners
corresponds to a set of size two
and now you apply multiplicative update
in this context you do a multiplicative
update you cap and now you learn
exponentially many things
you run into the corner of that simplex
and you have exponentially many corners
and you have an exponential speed up on
top of the 10 to the 20 but i do not
know how to do it
with in vitro selection we have all
kinds of theories but i'm not an an rna
so technically
have you exponentially
exponentially main corners but do you do
you select a
convex combination of these
yes you're working with a convex
combination which is a mixture you do a
multiplicative update you go outside you
project back in use an interview
projection which you can implement if
you can do camping
very very beautiful trick it's a similar
trick as we know slightly different
slightly different things the owners are
the investor i guess you go for the best
set of experts in this context
okay
okay good
so now
here's what we did for a very long time
i did it with many students mark
herbster
um and lots recently with wilder and
lots of people
okay
so you have 10 to the 20 different
strength and after a while
you have lots of
uh diversity some selfish streamed
selfish stream manages to dominate
without doing the job in vitro selection
people know this all the time they
create an initial soup and they do their
individual selection experiment and then
the egg soup gets exhausted some
bastard gene
took over it's totally useless
and you can't get rid of it so what they
do is they pour in a little bit of the
initial soup
and we did this with machine learning
so you mix in a little bit and soup for
a richer
enrichment you can do sloppy pcr you can
do many tricks
so we discovered this for instance and
we know we apply these online algorithms
in many contexts for instance disk spin
down problem
you have a
um
you want to figure out when to spin down
your disk and you want to adapt to the
behavior of the user if you have a lot
these are the idle times
if you if you know the idle times are
going to be short then you should have a
long time out you should wait it out
because it takes a long time to spin it
back up right a lot of energy loss
and if you have long timeouts then you
should spin down immediately and if you
do one of those multiplicative updates
which is natural in this context you
make up some
some
disk spin down times in the right range
you uh you update using e to the minus
usage of the energy energy and then what
happens after this all the guys all the
species the long species died out the
long time i've died out
so you're in trouble so you need to have
a fix
and the fix because you want to now
favor the other ones so you want to do
the multiplicative update to home into
the appropriate this spin down time
but then you also want to have long term
changes what if the if the
earth gets hit by a meteorite
how do you solve those problems
and nature solved this and we solved it
in machine learning and
the interconnection is mind-blowingly
interesting
so what you do is
you can take your multiplicative update
instead of projecting now what you do is
you take
alpha is one percent
99 of the weight vector you just got out
got and you put mix in one percent of
the uniform distribution
yeah that's all now this makes this
thing robust against change
okay and maybe nature uses mutation for
that purpose okay this is one of my
weakest statements please don't hold me
to that you know uniform distribution
yeah 10 to the 20 yeah and you don't
have 10 to the 20
yes yeah in nature you don't have 10 to
the 20. whatever the number of genes is
it's your n you know n 0 or whatever
okay so but there's an amazing what we
found out
this is kind of neat you can you can
talk about this forever you can model it
you can have a bayesian interpretation
over
exponentially many experts and do all
kinds of things and explain it but
there's a fancier one i have a question
do you like this stuff what how much do
you like
it's very subtle huh
okay
mutation might be immigration okay
yes uh some kind of process that mixes
that keeps the lower bound keeps the
lower bound in the weights so now here
comes a key
key thing
so imagine you have 10 000 genes and
then for a while you have nature where a
dominates has a high fitness factor then
d dominates has a high victor then g
then a again then g then d then a you
see i don't tell the algorithms this i
just run one of those algorithms
so this is the i measure the loss
of the algorithm so i always
let it vote with a particular gene and
then measure the loss okay good
it's very robust you can do all kinds of
loss functions with this so this is how
the total loss over time
grows of the best partition god knows
what the best partition is that's what
i'm after
this is the loss
of a partition of an arbitrary expert it
goes up much faster
now
here's the guy that this does
multiplicative updates
updates
it burns a into its weight space it
cannot learn d at all it has the bad
rate
i don't know why this is flat eventually
it got it it got it at this point yeah
it was long enough or it took a long
time the con if you make if you run this
longer
and it wipes out completely it would go
all the way straight and then
it
again here it remembers it immediately
when it go back to ah because it learned
this other one now i see good
okay now here is the one
that
this is the one that mixes in a little
bit uniform distribution it has the same
size bump each time the black one
it can recover rather quickly
now there's one update which has a
long-term memory and that's this update
instead of mixing a little bit of the
uniform distribution
what you mix in
is um
alpha times the past average
distribution
you keep two n weights
and you mix in a little bit of the past
average there's another scheme that i
will show you in a moment cumulative
yes cumulative average weight
okay so you can do that with pouring
again you soup you you know you poor and
poor and poor and you can do this you
need two cups that's all you need two
cups and a little calculator okay so you
do this
and
that update has the event has the
property that
when you come back to a again you only
have a small bump
so it learns a
and then you come back to a and it's a
small bump
here's a again and it's a small thumb
this is somehow like the immune system
is supposed to work exactly it's all
over nature there's a long-term memory
um
if you sing if you not learn songs if
you have learned a similar song before
you can learn it again
okay
it with genes if you have a species that
was resistant to some kind of sickness
if later on the same sickness shows up
you remember it fast
the combination
this one line
a multiplicative updates we talk about a
lot
i show about tricks right capping
uh um capping from the top lower
bounding from the bottom all kinds of
tricks if you add this one line
the algorithm does amazingly different
things
and it's just mind-boggling it does this
thing it has a long-term memory and i
actually won a prize with this
for my student it's the only money that
i earned honestly
but
we won the price and then we put it on
harder problems
than
that so my money is totally safe i
doubled the amount and i put in a lot of
problems so
it was fine okay so the punch line again
is
whenever you rediscover something the
bump is
best small is in hindsight god knows
what the environment is it can optimize
locally for
for the best gene and this would be the
best partition in hindsight
okay we learned well against the
petition in hindsight with a very simple
update it has two lines of code now
here's what happens in white space
the good guy
is pulled up fast
and now when a comes again
it's pulled up faster this this is all
exponential weights this pull up is
faster
or the first time green is pulled up
it's this and here it's pulled up faster
so
what happens is you have a long term
memory that brings out things that were
good in the past are brought up faster
by changing this one line of code
there's another one how you do it with
cups
so here
so you do a multiplicative update and
then you do a little soup exchange you
will see
so here's the multiplicative update
selection plus pcr here you can put in a
live model or whatever you want i
purposely state very simple selection
plus pcr right so it's very clear
there's no sex involved okay then
you have another
you keep two cups initially you
partition it into two here's your other
one and this one you just pass through
and now what is this step you just pour
epsilon here and epsilon here okay then
you do again your multiplicative update
on here you tip in your sheet and you do
this whole pcr thing and then you go
right and then you do again pcr over
here and you've got
and if you do this thing without knowing
anything it has a long-term memory
and we have an interpretation of this
we proved reasonably this this update
huh
we keep it fixed but there's tuning
problems working on those but the point
is i work with some of the best machine
learners and i drove them totally crazy
uh because we didn't have a bayesian
interpretation you see how do you get a
bayesian implication the bayesian
libertation would be you have you want
to have a prior on all possible
partition experts and then do an update
blah you see and if you choose the prior
right below it works so if you lower
bound the weights or you mix in a little
bit of the uniform very easy to get to
get a bayesian interpretation and for
this one
uh
for one mix in the past average or the
one that are shown with a cross-pouring
very hard to get a patient to be chasing
dovah's crazy
um
but then
wilder and dimitria mitchell
adamski they figured it out and we wrote
a paper pudding base to sleep
where you can show that if you have
exponential immediate partition experts
and some experts are asleep in the sense
that they don't vote they don't petition
in the pc participate in the pcr
they just sit outside and vote with what
everybody else does they abstain from
voting
and if you use this additional
abstaining trick which is also apparent
in this
collapsed version where these sort of
this whole population in some sense
abstains we don't fully understand all
the connections but we have proofs that
this thing works in an app shop
information theoretically what we do
what do we do
imagine you have
a million
a million genes and you want to learn
you're shifting the environment changed
catastrophically went
century
gene five is good second century gene 20
is good then for 100 none that's 100th
century nothing happens and then another
gene is good and you always shift around
between a small number of genes
we show that these kind of steams have
the following information theoretic
property you pay log of a million to
first learn
logan log of a million per gene the
first time you use it
the second time you have to switch to it
you only play log of 10.
so it's very very powerful
10 being the size of the small pool that
you shift between
the first time you pay a lot it's
information theoretical optimal it's
it's related what appears in the bound
is the number of bits to encode this and
of course if you have repeats
you your encoding gets better
okay
so here
how long how is long-term memory
realized in nature of course a lot of
you have thought about this junk dna sex
of course
you know we have already a paper in in
progress it's called we have putting
base to sleep
the next paper we already have the title
base and sex
but we have technical problems
and it's evolutionary listeners
so
so we did i showed you the conservative
update up about it the way it's lower
bounding the weights mixing past average
sleeping
nature i showed you a few of them of
course there's many many more i don't
know how to prove things about sex blah
blah blah but here's a bunch of other
ones
okay
so
multiplicative updates converge quickly
but they wipe out diversity
changing conditions require reuse of
previously learned knowledge
knowledge and and the diversity is a
requirement of success
and again the data is that what humans
are doing is we're eliminating diversity
because of the mixing that we're doing
and and we
do other tricks in machine learning okay
now i show you
one more open problems
okay
remember
i wrote out s i was the old s i times e
to the minus eta loss
a general organization is gradient of a
loss
by the way we know the conservative
update of we know can be explained using
the threshold loss function which
explains the conservativeness
but you have to use the gradients of the
losses
okay so you have your multiplicative
update in matrix case you cannot
multiply two matrices
and
preserve the properties what are the
properties of matrices we're looking at
before we had s being a share vector a
probability vector now it becomes a
density matrix which is a
matrix where the eigenvalues are
probability vector but you also have an
eigensystem
and
if you want to do the multiplicative
update there you first have to take a
matrix log of the matrix subtract the
gradient of the loss
and then matrix exponentially divided by
the trace we have bounds for this
there's a whole bayesian probability
calculus based on this it goes on and on
and on but i do not know whether nature
uses this update
whether there's an implication of
implementation of it like with in vitro
selection or something like that a
rudimentary experiment it's kind of a
mind-boggling uh open problem
actually this one you need to this had
many collapse convexity classes
collapsed recently based on this update
and so forth they had major influence in
complexity theory a lot of approximation
algorithms are based on this matrix
version of the hedge algorithm okay and
the key thing is what motivates this
thing is the quantum relative entropy as
a regularizer instead of the entropy
that goes through it goes back to
phenomena
okay that's all
any more questions
equation yes coexistence of parabolic
replication so if you have a parabolical
data
uh the rate of change of x equals x to
the power of something less than one
i know the
replicator equation it has to do with a
multiplicative update but there's a
variant like juan cadrowski and
mari which looks at the coexistence of
replicators if you have an exponent of
less than one yeah
x t plus one equals x uh something less
than one yeah then you have a similar
result to what you're doing with this
artificial threshold thing okay good i
would like to see that existence of
multiple replicated a different
replication
good good yes
so so this is kind of the interesting
thing our updates are so easy you can
analyze them we get i really got ideas
from nature believe it or not even
though i only read at a at a mad
scientist level
i don't really i'm not a biologist but
the the connection is really is kind of
mind-boggling do you know how those work
no no please talk to me afterwards
actually i work
i'm promiscuous in science i work with
anybody
okay so please talk to me actually you
can test i have tests
for testing whether there is a long-term
memory in any system you can do a
psychological test for it you can do a
biological test for it you can i don't
know yet how to
quantify quite how much long-term memory
there is but with experiment you can
test it and this is kind of i think the
next thing that has to be done
and then once you test it maybe you can
knock out sex and see where the sex is
responsible maybe you can knock out
various features of biology
but we know it exists it's useful
because we walk on the same problem we
know we have proofs that it works and
now we should test for it and
systematically disseminate
with existence
to consist the the phenomenon that when
you have a huge number of genes
and you shift have catastrophic events
that are long enough
and you shift
and you you you recover
faster if
you have had that resistance long time
in the past
very very very deep question and that
will really
show
experimentally that this happens in
nature and then i can go in and modify
the the nature's toolbox and see which
one does this
okay any biologist who wants to do
experiments please talk to me afterwards
yes uh i'm i'm very interested in the
notion of evolutionary processes having
long term yes the kind of memory that
you are showing here is a sort of rote
learning memory right you take a
snapshot of something that was useful in
the past and you keep it in case it's
useful in the future yes other kinds of
memory are sort of structural memory
which have the capability and principle
of doing some sort of generalization so
if you're faster to adapt to something
because you've seen things that were
like it in the past right not exactly
the same but we're doing we're doing
this as well
because what happens is
everything in machine learning is weight
vectors and there's predictions and so
forth
it's exactly that kind of thing if you
are similar to something in the past
you will
this weight will come up because it has
smaller losses a smaller gradient of
losses and it will be
learned faster also that we do yes so
that's like waiting over a feature space
so it's similar in feature space uh it's
similar in in there's a it would be the
relative entropy between you need a
certain concentration vector to do a job
and if the relative entropy between the
one that you want and the one that you
had is small then you would learn faster
it gets technically very fast
apologies to the biologists we look at
very very simple setups here
but we found some tricks
that look intriguing i mean the
connection is not far-fetched i think
yes
sorry
okay sorry i mean if your task was uh to
find the best pair of
uh rnas uh yes those binding was optimal
for some paralyzed thing is that
fundamentally different for you okay if
you look when you want to find let's say
let's say you want to find a combination
of 10
right so you have two choices of what to
do you can make up little chromosomes
with 10 10 genes each
and then have the species
compete based on the computation of them
and do the do the multiplicative update
we do that sometimes but we call it
expanded hedge but it's some what we do
is tricks to let us keep on working with
the same number of genes
but we do a mechanism on top and we
provably learn combinations of 10. i
guess i'm asking about if there's a
pairwise interaction between everything
and everything in your suit
and you want to find that the
air
sort of potentially n squared so you
have to find some subset of the n
squared or
which best bind
is that within your alexa column
it is within the lexicon i haven't
analyzed it uh you could you know you
can do all kinds of things in practice
you can if you have a rated combination
that works really well freeze it and
throw it in your gene pool
these these kind of
whenever you do entrepreneurialization
you can do amazing things what you can
do is
you
and this is really a portion of
something of the simplex
you can
go if something doesn't work well it can
go to an extremely low concentration
it can go back to 10 to the 20.
as long as it sticks around as long as
it lingers around it's fine and then it
can be picked up again so you can really
have a long-term memory
of size 10 to the 10 to the 20
while
while running and doing optimal things
and always bring it back up it's
mind-boggling and it's a property of the
simplex